In the "Fast and Furious" series,
death is little more than a speed
bump. So it's not a huge shock that a
character returns after their seeming
end in "Fast X," but you do have
to wonder just how it happened.
Obviously, spoilers for "Fast X" ahead.
There's a lot of ridiculous plot twists that
happen throughout director Louis Leterrier and
producer/star Vin Diesel's bombastic magnum
opus, "Fast X." But none are quite as hard
to swallow as the final scene's shocking
return. No, we're not talking about that
long-spoiled mid-credits scene that brings
Dwayne Jonson's Luke Hobbs back into the fold.
That sequence is astounding for its own
reasons, but what truly defies logic is
the revelation that, for some unknown period
of time, Gisele Yashar has been hiding in what
appears to be the nuclear submarine from
"The Fate of the Furious." The character
first appeared in 2009's "Fast and Furious"
played by future "Wonder Woman" star Gal Gadot,
and met her tragic demise in "Fast
and Furious 6," or so we thought.
Like her former lover Han, Gisele
has returned from the dead,
bringing with her a whole slew of
unanswered questions. Then again,
the series had already laid the groundwork
for a tenuously reasonable explanation for
her return -- though whether it increases or
undermines the dramatic tension is up for debate.
"After Gisele died, I didn't
know what to do. I was aimless."
In hindsight, it would almost be more surprising
if Gisele hadn't survived her "Fast 6" demise.
Characters from this franchise have survived
fiery explosions, gunshots to the head, and about
a hundred deadly car accidents. So falling from
around 15 feet onto an airplane runway probably
doesn't do a lot of damage in this universe, even
moving at the speed of a plane about to take off.
What is less believable in the Fast universe is
that she wouldn't immediately reconnect with Han,
which is likely why they'll explain her
faked death the same way they explained
his -- through the intervention
of Mr. Nobody and The Agency.
Aside from the fact that Nobody faked Han's
death for his own gain and could conceivably
have done so for Gisele, his involvement
is really the only way the Antarctica
prison-break subplot makes any sense. Brie
Larson's Tess is Mr. Nobody's daughter,
and her goal seems to be to help Letty escape, so
she would logically need to have a destination in
mind for her. So Gisele's presence at the climax
of this storyline almost outright confirms that
she's been involved with The Agency since her
"death" and is there at the behest of Tess.
Though we aren't yet sure what Tess, Gisele,
and The Agency are planning, it seems certain
that they've had this contingency ready for some
time. With Mr. Nobody and his ward, Little Nobody,
out of commission, the treacherous Agent Aimes
has been given the proverbial keys to the kingdom.
Perhaps Mr. Nobody noticed a change in
the tides and began to fear Dante and
Aimes' nefarious takeover of the Agency. With
a sense of paranoia rivaling that of Nick Fury,
Nobody might have closed ranks and kept
his circle of trust as small as possible,
which would explain why he couldn't have
revealed that Gisele was still alive even to Han.
"That means I can trust you. And that
is very rare in this line of work."
In this scenario, Nobody may have
sequestered the nuclear submarine
as a last resort base of operations for
Tess, Gisele, and possibly even Hobbs,
if he is also part of this clandestine
world-saving scheme. We're sure to get the
low-down on what Gisele and Hobbs have been up to
in the upcoming sequel, or sequels, to "Fast X."